what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to pop culture explain and
this week we're giving you our second
and probably last top five video
focusing on wanda vision as we finally
come to the end of this ridiculously
awesome series and what a crazy ride
it's been with lots of surprises lots of
twists and turns and today we're
counting down the top five moments
from this show so before we get into the
top five i want to throw in
an honorable mention that nearly made
the list but just
missed the cutoff which is at the end of
episode 5
when pietro shows up at wanda's door now
when it occurred this was huge for a few
different reasons right first pietro's
dead in the mcu as the show had already
reminded us having been killed in
avengers age of ultron so seeing him
alive was a shock in and of itself this
led to a lot of speculation that this
was not actually pietro but was someone
in disguise like mephisto or an illusion
mephisto had conjured to mess with wanda
but the big reason this got
everyone talking was that pietro was not
played by aaron taylor johnson who'd
previously portrayed him in the mcu but
by evan peters who had played the
character in fox's
x-men franchise because disney had
acquired fox and now owns the rights to
those characters the introduction of
evan peter's sp
show caused fans to go wild predicting
that he was the first step in the mcu
introducing the already established
x-men from the fox universe that wanda
had basically
pulled this version of pietro from a
parallel universe and that the arrival
of the x-men
must be imminent now if any of that were
true this would likely be
the number one moment on our list but
unfortunately the pietro thing
didn't really seem to be any of those
things he's not mephisto he's not
quicksilver from the x-men films
he's just ralph well technically ralph
boner the guy that agatho is claiming to
be her husband
which if i'm being honest is a bit of a
letdown and the reason
this is just an honorable mention but
starting off with the official list we
have number five
and in this moment we have episode
number seven where we find out that
monica rambo
has super powers and this makes the list
not for the shock factor but because
of its broader implications on the mcu
going forward from the moment that the
character of monica rambo was introduced
as a child in captain marvel fans were
speculating that at some point
we'd see her as an adult taking on a
central role in the mcu and the reason
for this is that fans of marvel comics
knew that monica rambo
was at one time known as captain marvel
in fact she'd had that title
long before carol danvers ever did so it
was pretty widely believed that we'd see
monica rambo get powers at one point and
one division
paid that off when it was revealed the
passing through the barrier to the hex
has
altered monica's dna and she now has
powers and while we haven't seen her
display any of these powers with the
exception of bullets flying through her
in
the finale of the of the whole season
then once again if you're a fan of
comics you know that when she does
she'll be a force to be reckoned with
now monica has had several nicknames in
the comics going by captain marvel
photon pulsar and spectrum at various
times and is one of the most powerful
heroes in the marvel universe and we
know that monaco will continue to be a
part
of the mcu even now that one division is
completely done and it's been confirmed
that she'll appear in captain marvel 2
where i'm sure
that we'll see her full powers on
display and i wouldn't be surprised if
she continues to be a mainstay of the
mcu
even beyond captain marvel 2. now at
number four we have another moment from
episode number seven which is the reveal
that wanda's neighbor agnes is really
agatha harkness and is the one who's
been messing with wanda the entire time
now the reveal itself is not that big of
a shock again as it's been speculated
for a while that agnes was in fact
agatha harkness by several people
including me but most seem to believe
that agatha was either there to help
wanda since she was one as teacher in
the comics or that she was working on
behalf of someone else like mephisto
nightmare or catholic but the moment we
get in episode number seven
seem to put all those theories about who
the big bad of the series is
to rest which is a bit disappointing but
it makes sense that characters that
powerful would be saved for movies down
the line instead of a tv series and
while it was surprising that agatha was
wanda's primary antagonist it was really
cool to see how adept at magic she
is in the mcu and if nothing else the
theme song that introduced her is agatha
harkness
absolutely slaps
[Music]
and i killed sparky too
[Laughter]
so coming in at number three we have the
post-credits scene following episode
number eight which reveals that sword
had not
only rebuilt the vision but had brought
him back online and this is a
really cool moment for a few different
reasons first it introduces the solid
white version of the vision which is a
great nod to the version of the
character that was around
in the comics and that a lot of fans
have an affinity for but he also just
looks awesome even more important than
that is what it's set up i love the
conversation between the rebuilt vision
and the created vision the one that was
made by wanda where they literally have
like this logical discussion that's
based on logic and philosophy in effect
the fake vision
defeated the real vision with like logic
and reason if only that worked in the
real world but it was cool
i don't really know what happened to the
fake vision i really want to know
because he just kind of took off
and that was that he got his memories
back and everything so he's probably
just kind of floating out out there
basically taking the same approach that
like bucky barnes did after captain
america and the winter soldier trying to
rediscover himself
but i think it'll be cool to see a kind
of reworked vision the real question you
have to ask is the question that we got
in that episode
if this fake vision was basically
rebuilt by sword and then sent out there
and then got his memories back from the
construct vision is he still considered
to be the real vision right is he like
vision recreated or is he a wholly
different version i have no idea and
i'll look to the comments for you guys
to tell me but at number two
we have the introduction of chaos magic
and the revelation of wanda
as the scarlet witch so this is kind of
a cheat and i'm basically counting
everything that happens at the end of
episode number nine is this one moment
where we see wanda's powers on full
display
followed by agatha's explanation or at
least partial explanation of her powers
now at various points throughout her
comic book history
wanda has been depicted as being an
extremely powerful person to the point
of being able to warp reality itself
not just on a universal level but on a
multiversal level and while we've known
that wanda has been warping reality to
some extent through the entire one
division series we see here that she's
basically able to create a new vision
seemingly from scratch which is far
beyond anything that we'd seen her do
before
in terms of power and so after seeing
this we know that we're dealing with a
super high level reality warper here
someone that can seemingly create
sentient life and while we also get the
introduction of chaos magic as a concept
into the mcu which i would imagine would
have huge implications down the road as
the mystic elements of the mcu are
fleshed out in the next doctor strange
film and beyond and we also get the
first time that wanda's ever referred to
as the scarlet witch in the marvel
cinematic universe and i actually think
that's pretty important for the
development of her character if wanda is
indeed going to be a villain in the
second doctor strange film the scarlet
witch is a much more menacing name
than just wanda and to that end i think
up to now the character has kind of
taken a backseat in terms of popularity
because she didn't have
any sort of nickname if fans didn't read
comics they might have no idea that she
was ever called scarlet witch so the
fact that she just went by her first
name was kind of odd i mean you have
characters called iron man captain
america black panther and
wanda so finally calling her the scarlet
witch significantly up to a coolness
factor
if nothing else and so this brings us to
our number one moment in the entire
series and for this video we're going
off script
this moment is wanda maximoff delving
into the dark hold
and this is a huge moment in the show
and the reason why is because
wanda doesn't know what she's doing and
that's why it's so cool it's because
wanda was just told by agatha there's
this book called the dark hole and this
dark hold will teach you how to use your
powers there's no understanding of the
significance of the dark hole there's no
knowledge of what it has its ties to she
literally just opens up a book that's
called the book of the damned and just
starts reading it this has
huge implications for the marvel
cinematic universe first and foremost if
the book really does have ties to
catholic that she's unwittingly
allowing herself to be influenced by
catholic's power that seems to be the
case because of the fact that she heard
her kids cry out and it's entirely
possible that catholic is influencing
her and then in turn will basically take
her over and then possess her in order
to use her for his own
end if that happens the entire marvel
cinematic universe is
because things are going to be crazy
right the level of power that's going to
be shown there is going to be unlike
anything that we've ever seen before
the other big thing that comes out of
this is that wanda is learning how to
use all these expansive powers that she
has
and agatha states broadly for us to know
the scarlet witch's power is beyond
that of steven strange and that means
that even if wanda ends up becoming a
bad guy
somehow survives the entire ordeal and
the marvel cinematic universe decides
not to kill her off like they've done
with so many of their villains and she
basically arrives back at avengers
mansion and goes forward as a good guy
with the full totality of her powers
that means the marvel cinematic universe
is gonna have to create stories that can
complement all those powers that she has
which means
bigger and better villains this is a
huge moment because it means that wanda
by exploring the full totality of our
powers and learning how to use them
is in effect a walking talking infinity
gauntlet i
love this but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
let us
know if you loved our top five list give
us your own list if you guys disagree
with any other and we will catch you all
later
peace